thank you hi everybody thank you for
having me here it's a great honor in
fact I went on the website and looked at
the list of people that we're speaking
here and wow it's amazing actually I
mean you guys should just give a check
to everybody that comes in here you'll
have the best growth fund in the world
so I want to talk to you about making
complicated things simple because I've
been trying I'm sure like you as well to
figure out what makes a company
successful and I've done that in
different phases in my life and you know
you look at things like what background
people came from you know they go to ivy
school universities etc it's hard to
find one thing that kind of defines
somebody that will be successful as an
entrepreneur and the one thing that I
saw it was common though between
everybody is that they took something
that was very complex I was complicated
and made it much simpler and that's part
of what I'm going to share with you
today before I do that how many of you
have seen the last lecture okay a lot of
you for those who haven't highly
recommended very strong piece and the
theme the main theme there it is that
basically you spend your life trying to
achieve your childhood dreams right and
that's kind of how it started for me as
well so this is second grade and I had a
friends and we were into electronic hits
so what we did is just try to make a
bunch of alarm systems and amplifiers
and things like that at least we were
thinking we were doing that in practice
it wasn't really working that great but
as we were doing that and spending a lot
of time doing it we talked about how
awesome would it be to create a product
we started designing it actually create
an electronics product that we will then
go and sell and my friend just came back
actually from from the US where he spent
a couple of years and he was telling me
that
we do that we will be sitting on top of
a skyscraper in Manhattan and we will be
sipping cocktails and having a lot of
fun that was second grade I then have
then know much about you know cocktails
and had no idea where Manhattan was but
it really sounded good so I figured out
that's something I wanted to do
something I want to create a product and
and start a company but that was just
you know kids dreams right 5th grade is
when you know a lot of things change in
my life the first thing is that I got
introduced to programming I went to this
class and we use this computer that I'm
sure a lot of you are not familiar with
it's called the zx81 it had one kilobyte
of memory and the biggest challenge
there was how do you write something
useful without running out of memory of
course and so you know i did that and
that kind of scouted my my love
computers but also something else
happened in fifth grade I had this
teacher she took me and a couple of my
friends and she had us help a few kids
in the class that he needed help with
their with their homework and with just
you know learning and so we went to
their house as I had specifically like
one child that was really not doing very
well and I went through his house a
couple times a week and helped him with
things from math to grammar etc and so
one day we had this grammar test and it
was really challenging one a lot of
people didn't do very well but the gaya
was I was you know helping he got an
a-plus and that was an amazing moment I
mean it felt just great it felt better
than then like being successful yourself
right and later on and went on and had a
few other experiences teaching other
people teaching classes as well and
that's one of the things that I highly
recommend to everybody first it's a
great introduction to management so a
lot of things that are very similar
between teaching and mentoring people
and in
managing and the other reason that's
especially important for people who are
doing startups or one of those startups
is that you have to learn how to take a
very complicated concept and make it
really simple right especially if you
want everybody to understand it that's
exactly like creating a product a new
product that you need to make sure that
you take a complicated problem and you
make it really simple so that everybody
understands so moving on to high school
yeah there's this small insurance
company that the owner there heard that
I was doing programming and he wanted me
to come in the summer vacation come and
help them build this software that will
automate their business and so I did
that over the summer it was you know for
a kid it was a great money and it was a
lot of fun to actually the thing that
was the most fun is when you know once
the software was in place and the people
in the office started using it they
started every time it came there they
started thanking me and I didn't do
anything you know new or extra every
time I came there I it was still the
same software that I built before but
they start thanking me for you know this
is the social they've been working with
all the time and that is one of the
pleasures of building a product and
actually that's the same thing that
keeps us running today at house we have
you know there's a lot of difficult
moment when you're on a company a lot of
moments where you feel like you know
everything is against you nothing is
working everything is going to fail and
those moments I go to the App Store to
look at our reviews we're lucky enough
to have you know five-star average
reviews 200,000 review so there's plenty
to choose from and and you look at that
and it gives you the sense that you're
actually helping somebody because making
money at the end of the day is nice you
can look at the kind of the bottom line
how much money the company is making etc
it doesn't really give you that sort of
gratification then people that actually
say something nice in their review and
and they thank you for what you've done
in fact my favorite review not my wife's
you'll see in a second why but my
favorite review is somebody that wrote
that if house was a man I would
marry him so I read that one at one of
the company meetings and I spent that
night on the couch but yeah so this is
where you guys are and this is the
university I went to and I was in this
program that was really lucky to be in
this program that pay for my tuition and
living expenses and stuff like that but
I learned a big lesson there after year
and a half I got him I got a mail and it
said that I'm getting kicked out of the
program and what happened is that I you
know I was also an okay student i did my
my job but I didn't really do enough to
be honest right i mean the whole idea
there was that you're supposed to do
extremely well and really get the best
grades and take extra curriculum et
cetera and I didn't that I'll do that
that was lazy and so I got kicked out
and I had to start working while I was
at school including by the way working
as a teacher which was kind of fun so I
learned from that but the biggest thing
I learned is that it's not enough to be
you know to be talented in something you
actually have to work very hard and
that's a lot i see a lot of startups
that that they don't get that that's
kind of a big piece right i mean it's
not just about you know being able to do
something it's about being able to work
through it night and day and it is hard
so it's it's something that is a very
important to keep in mind and that's
something that cannot be simplified by
the way unfortunately so want to talk
about how you select your partners let's
say you decide to do a start-up so I've
had this idea for a first startup in i
think it was 97 or something like that
and i had worked with a friend of mine
and we worked together before I liked
him he liked me everything was cool and
then we wanted to run it we went to a VC
and that bc said that they they are
willing to invest in me that they don't
want to invest in that in that other
partner and so that thing didn't work
out so something wasn't right there
either with a partner or with the VC but
it just didn't work out and the whole
thing kind of
failed and nothing happened and choosing
father is something that's actually very
very difficult and I failed in that many
times actually that's just one of the
examples but I did get lucky once and
that's when I went to Thailand I went to
Thailand and I went on the bus similar
to this one because i have to get from
Bangkok to cosas muy which is in the
south of town Thailand usually people
flight but didn't have enough money to
fly so took the bus it's 15 hours bus
direct and then i went i said in the
back of the bus and then there was like
my wife-to-be came on board and she was
with two other friends and they said the
front of the bus and so the bus driver
comes to them and basically walk her by
the hand and tells her oh you have to
sit here next to this guy because other
people are supposed to come on the bus
so she she's doing that right and then
we start talking for for fifteen hours
and actually she did most of the talking
I have a hard time even talking 40
minutes straight like here but but it
was a lot of fun and then we got married
not not in Thailand three years later we
moved in together before that and other
things and and then I realized that
maybe you know the algorithm for getting
married is better than the algorithm for
fighting startup entrepreneurs and even
though like I know fifty percent don't
work out but it still may be better than
how we select partners and if you think
about it you know just dating first
right and then moving in together right
how many partners do that like many
times people just decide okay we're just
going to do it and we're going to share
everything and from that on that day on
you guys are married right and
everything that's happening with this
company is kind of that's the way it is
right so it's it's kind of a good idea
if it's possible I never did it but you
guys should try it maybe is to actually
date and living together with your not
not literally with your future partners
but invest more in that it's very
important actually the two more the two
most important things that I've found in
in you know whether started going to
success succeed or not is a to pick the
right people which are your partners and
and the first people you hire right and
in n bees just work hard which we've
talked about before so sometimes it
seems like there is there are two
options for people that you know first
students just are about to finish there
or just people in the university right
one option is you drop out of college
and by the age of 25 you become a
billionaire right and then the other
option is you finish your school and
then you go work somewhere and then you
do that for the rest of your life and
forget about the startled dream right
well it's not really like that and you
know we met this when house was starting
to kind of get more steam we met with a
bunch of entrepreneurs and one of them
is a guy named almost Bill Nighy and he
has an amazing story where he started
his company in his 50s okay so that's
when he started his company and he
became hugely successful he went public
he sold his company for eventually for
four and a half billion dollars and so
he really was successful even though he
started very late so it's never too late
I mean obviously it's easier to do it
before you have kids a DNI are doing it
with you know now three kids and when we
started we had to which is not easy but
there are some advantages to and one of
those advantages is that you can
actually learn on the way if you go work
in some other places so I joined ebay in
2001 and I've been there for for a while
originally when I wanted to learn is why
ebay became successful right how come
the community kind of got together and
became what it is I was never able to
figure that piece out so it's kind of
hard really now in retrospect when I
look at house I kind of understand that
you know it starts with building
something that's useful and then there's
just additional steps along the way it
happens kind of you know day after day
it doesn't happen overnight but the time
I was really trying to figure out what's
the secret sauce what's the magic that
makes it happen right and there really
isn't at the end
they a magic right it's just something
useful and then just keep going at it
right but I did learn a bunch of other
things so a few things that that I've
learned at eBay the first one is that
when you look at user flows it's really
important that you keep them really
really simple it's you know a lot of
jokes about users and and how
complicated different things are for
users but the reality is that you know
when people are using your product they
don't care about your product they care
about everything that's going on in
their life and they have this little
attention span for everything that's
that's going on with with the product
they're using and so it's really
important to make it really simple for
them and not let them guess and i'll
give you some examples later on when we
talked about when we will talk about
that product design so that's the first
thing i learned the second thing is a
little bit unfortunate but i learned how
to let people go and it's something that
is really easy to you know kind of push
away something you really don't want to
deal with you know everybody wants to be
a nice person and wants to make you know
things work out but the reality is that
in most of those cases it's best for the
person you're letting go and for the
company to just separate ways as soon as
poss as soon as you realize that there's
something wrong I made the mistake of
waiting too long and it was a disaster I
actually made that mistake not at the
same level but i will let things go for
a little bit too long even at house the
first time but since then it become kind
of a little bit easier in a way it's
never easy it's always a challenge but
many times what your fears are are much
worse than what it really is in most
cases the person anyway kind of realizes
that it's better for them and they were
just kind of waiting for that and all
the people that work with that person
are just like after that they come to
you and tell you Oh why'd it take so
long you know and and it's kind of
unfortunate but that's that's really the
reality of things it's best for
everybody so these are some of the
things that are not so fun in having you
know your own company but it's it's
something necessary and many times
there's just no way around it you can
interview as much as you can as much as
you want but
you're going to make mistakes so that
was the second thing that I learned that
ebay the third thing I learned is maybe
how not to do some things right and when
you work at a big corporation and a
company that's public it's you know
things are kind of a little bit more
bureaucratic they have to be more checks
and balances and it really is difficult
to get people to feel empowered right to
feel like they can actually get things
going they can actually come up with
ideas and work on them and that's one of
the things that I really tried at house
not to get into that situation we try to
hire people that are very
entrepreneurial and let them kind of run
with it obviously it's a lot easier in a
smaller company but that's something
that's that's extremely important is to
trust the people that are with you and
let them do what what they realize is
the right thing to do last but not least
we have this really great program at
ebay called leadership ebay and it's
where you get a bunch of people together
that you know from different places in
the organization and it's usually like
small groups five or six people and and
they talk about you basically there's a
like a group leader right and you talk
about things that stay within that room
that's kind of the understanding right
and people share really big problems
that they have sometimes even personal
problems I mean they've been even like
tears in those scenarios and I shared my
kind of my thing my mother problem i was
having let me ask you first how many
people here were not born in the US ok
so like more than half right so you know
it's it's it's kind of hard to talk
about those things but but sometimes you
feel a little bit as an outsider in some
situations and i think for you guys it's
actually a lot easier because you came
here when you were when you were you're
still young and and you go to school
together and that actually helped a lot
I came in when i was in 30 right and
when i was around engineering folks it
was a lot easier because we speak
engineering but when it comes to like
situation where you work with a lot of
business folks and especially when I was
not here still for now
here for 15 years but when I was here
just like for you know a few years and
they talk about their experiences from
school or sports or other things I
wasn't really into you really feel like
an outsider it's not their fault it was
kind of my fault that I was feeling that
way or at least that that's how I
thought and so I shared that with the
group and then one of them told me
something that that I'll never forget
and he said that you're looking at the
wrong way you're really the American
dream that's really what what you are
and that's how you should feel about it
you came here and now you're part of the
successful company and you're doing so
well in that that stayed with me right
that that actually helps a lot to see
that sometimes the things that you
imagine aren't really there right so
that was kind of a really good
experience for me so let's talk about
house so how did it all start we bought
this house in not too far away from here
and it's an all ranch from nineteen
fifty-five you walk in it was never
touched so you walk in you turn right
there is this white kitchen never
touched it's basically like original the
way it was back when it was you know
when it was created first time you keep
going going to this bathroom it's a neon
pink bathroom right and I try I'm a
little bit tall so I try to stand there
and like basically i hit my wall my head
and the in the ceiling all the time
right so had good bones we went with it
and a couple years later when we had a
little bit more money we wanted to
remodel it right so we started the
process we thought it's going to be a
lot of fun right we all walked around
furniture companies furniture stores
right and you know liked all the vibe
there etc we thought it's going to be a
lot of fun and we started and we were
looking for a professional for an
architect that had experienced
modernizing ranch homes and you look at
the internet is like you get to this
weird website it's kind of loading
really slow it has flash and there was
some of these I thought that'll do
something really cool with it so you
have to wait for 30 seconds until the
animation stars and you're trying to
figure out like what's going on there
and you can't really find out what's
like where the professionals that I need
right and eventually we went with
somebody that
our friend recommended and it actually
didn't turn out that well so we had to
after we did all the plans we have to
basically delete them and start all over
again and later on when we talk to other
people they told us they had the same
experience and then we they sent us to
the bookstore borders when it was still
in downtown university right to look at
books and magazines right and get ideas
so we would go there and buy a bunch of
books and magazines and go page by page
and try to figure out you know what is
it that we both like and that was a very
inefficient process we're like you know
this 21st century we do everything
online travel is online why isn't this
industry online and then we went to talk
to our friends and they had the same
problems right just other people in the
neighborhood and so you know figure
there's got to be a better way to do
this and this is how how has got started
so it really started as a fun project
that we that this is actually the first
version of the website that I can see
designed and not a great designer but
but actually the first designer that I
worked with later on told me that for
engineer it's not too bad so but the
first thing you did is deleted got rid
of the black background so if you can
actually read the text and so but it was
a really fun project I just did it over
you know the weekends and addy started
working with the community after it was
it was there the development piece worst
part was fun because you know I was like
managing group at ebay I didn't really
have been doing coding for a few years
and this was kind of back to basics
right back to actually contributing
something and doing something that that
moves the needle right in making all the
decisions is fun right you don't have to
go through a bunch of you know approvals
etc to get something going so that was
great and then a deal was working with
the homeowners with the architects and
started in the Bay Area right and we
started having like a small community
there but then what happened next was
really amazing because homeowners
started telling other homeowners and
professionals started telling other
professionals as well as the other way
around right professionals with our
homeowner
I etc so it started spreading and we
started getting people signing up from
New York from LA from Chicago etc and we
started opening metro areas for them you
can see here but there was an option to
browse by Metro we just started with
like San Francisco and then we added up
as we got more people asking us to add
more more areas as well as more
professional types from architects to go
to interior designers to landscapers to
contractors etc as well as a bunch of
them that we never knew even existed
like there's a different kitchen
designer this different bathroom
designer it's different than a regular
interior designer so it's pretty you
know it's a very involved industry and
what happened one day is that we had a
friend of ours like one of the parents
from the kids school she came over to
our house and told us all excited that
her sister in Oregon just heard about
heard about this amazing website that
helps you design your home and she
should check it out and she was like you
kidding me I was like one of the first
you know people on the side I know the
people who started it and we thought you
know that that's really awesome and
maybe there's something here that's you
know that's bigger right and at that
time we already started having like
several hundreds of thousands of you
know people on the site every month in
several thousands of professionals so we
started talking to some and other
entrepreneurs and learn what you know
what we should be doing right and they
gave us some really good advice like one
of them said that don't enter if what
you want is to exit right and that's
really true and it rang really well with
us because we started it as a fun
project we liked it right and and it was
solving our own need and so you know we
weren't really in this for for the exit
and that's a much better way to get into
things much more healthy because if
you're looking for the exit you're not
going to get it maybe I don't know there
could be some businesses where way it
works but at least our experience has
been that's a much healthier way to get
into it and do something that you're
really passionate about so new beginning
so I never done scary things like this
and so taking risk is something that's
that's hard
right I mean you're kind of giving up
your full-time job and you have to you
know go into this new exciting thing but
but it was a lot of fun and obviously
don't regret doing it had some trouble
explaining it to my mom but it kind of
worked out and then the best thing about
it was that I was doing it together with
my wife with addy and you know it's just
this partnership where you really have
the same interest you don't have to
second-guess your partner you realize
that's not for everybody I've heard that
for many people they I could never do
this with my wife kind of thing but but
it really helps when you both have the
same interests and you're both looking
in the same way at the same time we were
very complimentary we were each coming
at it from a very different perspective
with different skill sets etc so it's
always fun of course when you're doing
it with somebody that that you like
raising money so how do you simplify
raising money right there's tons of
books on that and lectures and
everything right it's a complicated
thing so it seems right it is
complicated so there's one simple way I
realized is you do one company that's
successful and then it's easy to raise
the you know the next ride the next
money for the next company but that
doesn't work if you don't have that
first company so that was ruled out yeah
I don't know that's a great question
it's when the VCS are chasing you after
that yeah so anyway that doesn't work
right so what do you do so for us it was
basically us bootstrapping it solved a
lot of the problem and it's not for
everybody but it definitely is a very
viable way to make things work because
what happens is that you come to
investors where you have something
that's already there it's already has
been proven right people are using it
and you've shown that you can you knew
your founder co-founders right we're
doing it on your own with very little
budget that's really what investors are
looking for right that's an indication
that you guys can actually make it
happen right and it made our life a lot
easier so the first invest
sir that we found his name is orange dev
and he's a well-known kind of angel
investor here in the valley and he had a
bunch of successes before and we really
liked him because it was very much
profounder so we didn't feel like you
know he was trying to you know to get a
better deal or something like that it
was really trying to help us and in fact
to this day he's you know usually
helpful on a variety of different things
and really just become became a friend
and then a few months later or in kind
of talk to us about you know maybe we
should get a VC to join and we were you
know not so crazy about you know getting
more investors but we agreed to just you
know kind of have coffee with a few and
things went really quickly really fast
we work with Sequoia they were great and
Alfred Lynch on our board he was
previously at Zappos and in he's just
become part of the family so that's been
really a positive experience for us but
it was made a lot more a lot easier
because of the fact that we bootstrapped
the company so building the team so
these are our first two employees they
still with the company they started
working out of our own house this is our
first engineer of here and sheila was
our editor but really the first few
people you hire are critical because you
know you've probably heard the middling
times that a player's bring a player's
it's really the way it is and we got
really lucky I are the bunch of people
actually a bunch of them out of Stanford
that are you know just really smart
really capable really nice people and
that's kind of what you're looking for
when you're starting out because then
they bring their friends and then people
that come to interview they see who you
already have right and they want to come
work with those folks right and the
other thing is that they actually helped
a lot with setting the culture they
actually have the responsibility they
helped with the culture just as a DNI
did they set the culture we have a
family culture you know there's like
things that are symbolic like
celebrating birthdays every week and
having our house slippers so if you feel
at home and having rooms in the office
that are after room
in the house but really the things that
make the most difference is just having
nice people that everybody kind of
enjoys and feels like they can just be
themselves we don't have to play games
so that's I cannot you cannot
underestimate how important that was at
least for us it was hiring is another
thing that's kind of very hard to do
it's one of those things that's very
complicated and you cannot simplify it a
DNI interview every person that joins
the company it used to be both of us now
it's one of us interview every person
that joins the company and that really
helps maintain the culture that that we
have and that's really important and you
learn a lot from from interviews
actually I actually learned more from
interviews with people with didn't
accept and people that we did actually
the best idea comes from those
interviews of people that you eventually
don't join the company somehow it
happens that way I don't know why but
you know it's really a good thing to do
when to monetize so for us we've started
with just building growing the company
we decided not to monetize in the first
year or two and that turned out to be a
good decision for us investors helped us
a lot with that decision and so we
started monetizing a little bit later on
when we had ikea and lows and others
approached us and that gave us the time
to build a company so if you have that
that's a really great luxury to have
today we have three revenue channels
doing very well we're doing comers we're
doing we have subscription for
professionals as well as brand
advertising and you know just the pro
subscription channel it has over ton of
people in Orange County that are
managing that that channel so it's
because it become really big but that's
because we've done it in the right time
when the community was already big and
and very strong heating walls so that's
that happens a lot so there's tons of
moments where you're just like so
frustrated things are not working out we
had a lot of those moments and so it's
really easy to give up you know that's
what happens with love startups people
give up and we
probably close to it a few times but
there's a few things that you know just
a few of those stories that kind of help
us keep it together so one of them this
is from the last lecture where he talks
about how the walls are there for the
other people so that they don't reach
the goal before you do right that's
that's how you think about it so so
that's a very strong one the second one
is how many of you know the story about
the two frogs just a few okay so two
frogs jumped into a milk jar and they
started drowning right so they start
jumping and jumping and then one of them
gives up and they just drawn and died
and then the other frog keeps jumping
through the night and the milk turns
into butter and then they're able to
jump outside of the jar and they stay
alive right so we always I always tell
me I did a story and then she was
telling it like we're telling to the
entire company and whenever we had
though we have those difficult moments
that's what we kind of remind ourself is
you just have to keep jumping eventually
it will work out the third one is this i
have this page bookmarked on my on my
browser and every time i had a difficult
moment i was reading it it's from a
german vc he's actually kind of calling
it as it is and saying how founders are
not necessarily really the nicest people
to kind of be around with but what
they're best at is moving walls and
getting things done when others give up
right so when ever had at the focal
meant i look at this and say you know
what then go ahead and quit you'll never
make it anyway i'm not going to do that
right we're just going to keep going
we'll find a way so these have been very
helpful at least to me product design so
products done is very important
obviously for us we're a visual platform
we've you know we have these apps and
the website and now one of the mistakes
we've done that we have entire designers
early enough and so we worked with an
outsourced designer for a while and
really that's one things you want to do
is if design is a core part of your
product you want to get those folks to
be full time as
soon as possible today we have an
amazing design team and that's really a
huge benefit the other thing is you want
to be very involved in the design
process still designers you know for
example our designers are mostly in
their 20s and so they can do things like
you know buttons that have just icons on
them but you know it without like text
next to it but that doesn't work for
everybody you know maybe you know people
in the bay area that are remodeling
you'll have a lot of 20-something right
that have been successful in some
startup and so they are now building
their home but most of the country it's
like people in their 30s 40s 50s right
so when you have this button you kind of
need to have a caption next to it so
that people actually understand what it
does so things like that is where you
want to be really involved in the
process and that to this day I'm very
involved in you know everything that's
going on many times you cannot be
involved in everything of course but
many times you know i would get involved
in things like moving things to pixel
around or things like that so this is
last slide and it's like question that
many times people don't really ask is it
worth it you know and and it's not
obvious right today it's easy to look at
it and and you know we've we've had
great success we have you know 25
million people on the on the platform
every month there's you know thousands
of hundreds of thousands of
professionals etc but it was a lot of
hard work throughout right and so I
think one of the questions that i was
asked before is does it like what would
you tell yourself you know when when you
were younger before you you started
house and the truth is that I wouldn't
tell anything because if I totally the
way it is probably wouldn't do it you
know it's like sometimes just better to
jump in and and nothing too hard about
too much about you know what's going to
happen and just you know jump to the
cold water so that's it then when I open
up to questions
good that is your house with that what
was under the eye on Italy your house
what should happen there so when you
click on your house you you get to see
basically you're your own profile you
can be signed it dude sorry you can
design your own house there you don't
design your own house no but you can
come up with ideas for it you sorry you
mentioned feeling like an outsider some
people say that appear a dredge in some
way do your feelings do you think that
way otherwise that could you repeat the
questions but yeah yeah hey you
mentioned you feel sometimes like an
outsider you feel ur was an advantage
for you feel the wave seen the things
that way no I don't see it like that
anymore but at least at the time that
was that was what what was going on yeah
questions add a question about the
culture at the company and what we do to
reinforce that sure so in terms of the
culture that's one of the things that
are extremely important to us at the end
of the day it's really about the people
so as much as we can do a lot of things
right we do a lot of things we every
week we celebrate birthdays we have
people's pictures on the wall with like
family pictures on the wall right we do
a lot of other fun events etc but really
it's all about the people that that you
hire that's eventually what's really
setting your culture right if you hire
the right people and that's why we're
interviewing every person that joins
right if you hire the right people and
they're just you know getting into this
culture where everybody feels good with
each other and everybody's having fun
then it just happens by itself so it's
really i think most of the credit goes
to the team who is creating the culture
more than anything else yeah
so you mentioned that by during a
childhood you did have this vision of
starting a product or a company someday
but while you were working for me before
nine years I've had some see you
experience before that were you thinking
I'm probably going to try something
again over you like this is my life now
and let's see what happens what was your
going on in your mind that time yeah I I
was thinking about it and it's easy very
easy of course to get used to you know
once you're in a big company that's
successful it is just easy to stay
around so it I stayed around for longer
and it was also fun right I mean I
enjoyed a lot of it and I had a great
French there and we were doing some
interesting things but yes I did have
this saw that sometimes it will happen
absolutely yeah yeah yes connecting of
the mind foundation model that was it
hot like to be convinced like people
well with you and your company you don't
have a monetization model is that so
that what I'm sorry technique you you
know why should I doesn't have a revenue
model yet yeah that's that's a great
question so I'll just repeat the
question right so when we didn't have a
monetization model in place yet how did
we convince people to to join the
company I think the first people where
first of all some of them we've known so
that helped a lot of course to establish
trust and we did talk about the plans to
monetize right and so that helped but
definitely in the beginning it wasn't
easy like in the first few months at
least until Sequoia one Sequoia came on
board will be it was easier to explain
to people that if Sequoia kind of is
invested in that it's definitely
something that's worth doing but before
that it wasn't easy at all so the first
few hires were extremely extremely
challenging definitely and not just
because of that reason also because you
know we didn't prove herself yet
although we could talk about the fact
that the site was there there were
hundreds of thousands of people on it we
could talk about the potential etc so so
that did help
yeah the way you explained it it sounded
like you just put up the website and you
just kind of suddenly magically appeared
is there something specifically that
you're going to tribute to raising a lot
of attention to your website or bringing
a lot of attention to your website I
think the main thing is that the need
was there right people were having these
problems just like we were having those
problems so they were just happy to have
something that solves their their
problem right the other thing that
helped us a lot is that the
professionals the architects the
designer is the contractor they used
houses a tool right so they were going
and telling their customers you know
what why don't you first collect some
ideas instead of trying to kind of
explain to us what you want because some
people say modern and they actually mean
traditional right it's really hard to
figure this out and so for them it has
made their life a lot easier in fact we
have a lot of testimonials from
professionals that are saying that
instead of a nine months project it
became like a three-month project just
because it's helped so much with
explaining what you want yeah I say it
again how do you have you create the
work home separation yeah yeah yeah we
have three kids twelve eight and one and
so one was obviously conceived while we
were at the house so we kind of insist
on making it more complicated and in it
it's not easy there is no like slam dunk
answer there's a lot of things we're
trying to do like you put try to put
some limits although you cannot
realistically not talk about work at
home it's just too challenging but we
try to put limits especially around the
kids right so we try to make sure that
we have our time with them that's just
dedicated to them and we made a rule at
some point that we're not going to work
over the weekend because in the
beginning we were like you know seven
days a week and we made this rule that
we're not going to work over the weekend
outside then maybe a few you know
specific hours in and that helps a lot
too but it's never easy it's never easy
and it's just a lot of you need to talk
about it and come up with ways to
improve it
and the other thing that we realized is
that as you hire more people this
foreign people in the company now it
doesn't come any in this incoming easier
so you think it would but but it doesn't
so that's something that we're
constantly working on and trying to get
more help etc good yeah I want to talk
about the future how many how many time
and resources the you invest in planning
the next tip on how to keep keep keep
being innovative and such a successful
as you are right now yeah that's a great
question so how much time do we spend on
on basically planning the future and
keep being innovative right so we've had
a lot of copycats in the last few years
and we we had anywhere from sites in
China that copied like our entire site
including the JavaScript including they
copied the videos and they just put
voiceover and so so you know obviously
and there were copycats also in the US
including by some larger companies and
so it's always important that you keep
right investing in the future right and
so that's really the thing that keeps us
ahead ahead of the game and we try to
allocate we kind of work on a portfolio
strategy right in terms of what we
invest in and we try to allocate some
significant amount of resources to kind
of building the next thing and helping
solve the next the next problem in
looking at both from the needs
perspective and a technology perspective
so in one end you want to look at what
problems are there in remodeling and
design that we haven't solved yet and on
the other end we try to look at what new
technologies exist for example around
images for example there's a lot of
things we're trying to do around
graphics and figuring out what's in the
image and things like that what can we
do around that and then figure out how
it will you know work into work its way
into the product yeah I associate a lot
of the success of the platform with the
simplicity you mentioned but also
tasteful content are betrayed good taste
yep good question how do you make sure
that you know the content on the site is
the best content possible right so its a
mix of first of all an amazing community
that by definition you know all the pros
that are on the site have amazing work
so that has been the number one factor
and all that and also a great homeowner
community that helps us by their choices
both implicit and explicit helps us
figure out algorithmically what is the
best content we also have an editorial
team that's helping with a bunch of
different things and helping curate
content so mix of all those strategies
yeah great would you say that you feel
at home in the United States and have
you ever thought about getting going
back to Israel yep good question so do I
feel at home yes I do now I've been here
for 15 years and that's a long time so I
do feel at home and we've been living in
this house for for a long time and we've
been working on it and so it does feel
like home and Palo Alto feels like home
but i do have you no place in my heart
for for israel my family is there you
know i love the food I love the beach a
lot of different things there so we go
visit all the time right and you know
going back is a question that I'm sure a
lot of people here are thinking about
right as well right at some point and
you know from a start-up perspective I
think you know the U has amazing
opportunities right that don't really
exist anywhere else in the world I think
the fact that you have so many people
kind of around you know with with kind
of an opening stores towards innovation
it's really amazing it doesn't exist in
other parts of the world at least from
what I've seen but i can assume that you
know for folks that are you know that
can go back to countries where there is
a lot of opportunity and those are
larger place is really small place right
but places where there's a large
community that's something that that
could be interesting that said there's
really no
nothing that compares to Silicon Valley
in the world and coming here and in
being in palo alto has been you know
it's been a great part in our i think in
our success oh and go to up to another
continent given that i see you still
have a huge potential here in us and der
i have learned that you plan to expand
in 15 countries what was your rationale
yeah so we recently open offices in in
London and Berlin in Australia and Japan
and Russia and so we're expanding to
Europe and some other parts as well the
rationale is that there are design is
something that is global right and
actually we found that a lot of people
in the US like to see international
design we've uploaded this amazing
apartment that an architect in Midland
put together and like everybody it was
like drooling over it right and so
there's a lot of appetite for that and
so we feel that by going global we don't
always we don't only add additional
markets to the platform but actually
this mix of styles and ideas from all
over the world is creating something
that is you know greater than the sum of
its parts yeah one word there yeah in
what ways do you feel that your career
and successes and entrepreneur has been
affected by the Israeli culture in your
upbringing
so yeah I mean a lot of people talk
about Israel its startup nation there's
a book like that I think too and there's
a lot of reasons why that may be the
case including you know investment in
technologies and and bunch of other
things that are cultural but if you look
at successes of startups you see that
it's all individual at the end of the
day right every startup is different so
it's hard to say that there is like one
rule of why 11 would succeed then the
other would not I think it's all at the
end of the day you know about you as a
you know as a person and the
opportunities you're exposed to and of
course you know how lucky you are to
that helps coming from someone to such a
technical background what changes in
your own thinking did you have to make
to work on it such a design oriented
product okay so the question was giving
my background as an engineer I'm
assuming right is you know what it was
it like to work on a design oriented
project I think I learned a lot I think
there was a lot to learn I didn't know a
lot in the beginning and I certainly
made a lot of mistakes I think I
mentioned one before right not bringing
more designing on board earlier on but I
also had a lot of people to learn from
we hired a bunch of people now in the
design team but also in the editorial
team in other places and we work with
our community as well right and they
have a huge part in making this
successful and so it was definitely a
huge learning experience although I
wouldn't still call myself like an
expert designer in any way she mentioned
one of the hard things were learning to
let people go quickly enough so what are
some of the signs will look forward
making better system and how do you
convince yourself make the right
decision yeah so the question is when
you let somebody go how do you make that
decision how do you know if it's the
right decision or not I think every case
is different to be honest you know
sometimes it's based on just cultural
fit sometimes it can be based on
abilities writer or performance and it's
never easy so it's really all
visual decisions other questions they're
in the back give me your your kids go
out to college what do you think is
gonna be the advice that you give to
them to listen to the dead that would be
the first advice no really just to do
what they're passionate about that's
really the other day what it is because
you don't want to live in a life that's
kind of fake right you want to do
something you're enjoying and whether
that's a start up or something else I
think it's all good as long as you're
enjoying it so that's the only advice I
that I have this very interesting sport
right now where it's like one of the
darlings of the Silicon Valley and it's
all nice and shiny and bright right now
as a person of just you see that inside
of it also do you think we have a
tendency to just paint think that
success and failure just what insights
do you have in being at this point of
time you're just going yeah so you know
it's definitely true that when you look
from the outside you only see the
successors right you don't see all the
difficult moments you don't see
everything that's going on and you know
that's why a lot of founders talk about
this roller coaster that exists right so
when you're in on the inside you know
that things are not always as they look
from the outside right that said you
know now it's we're in a different phase
in the company right so before that it
was really about are we gonna survive or
not right and now it's really about you
know I'm going to be successful in this
market are we going to be able to you
know succeed internationally like we
were successful in the US right our new
initiatives you know marketplace etc
they're going great but can we get it to
where we wanted to get a net cetera
right so that those are the type of
discussions that that exists right now
but it doesn't change it's still all
about you know working hard and trying
to move walls that aspect of it never
changes yeah right
could you share with us one of these
running against the wall situations
there's there's certainly a lot of those
moments right for example the hiring
people is always is always something
that's hard to do especially hiring you
know engineering this in this market as
you guys probably know is something
that's hard to do right and and
sometimes get pretty crazy right and so
you want to you know you look at that
and you want to grow your team and you
have more stuff to do that you know is
going to create a lot of benefit for the
company but then you can only hire that
fast right and you're trying to hire
people that are very you know very
strong so you don't want to compromise
on that right so you have all those
different things that kind of working
together and it just makes it a lot
harder right and it is frustrating that
you can move as fast as you want to move
just because you can't hire people fast
enough so that's just one example
there's a lot of other ones other
questions
you